in Marvel Comics Legion is incredibly
powerful but often neglected mutant son
of Professor Charles Xavier who
basically has as many superpowers and
rights as once a second side is nutty
little brain over the years he's helped
save the world but also nearly destroyed
it a few times too now that the
character has his own surreal
live-action series it's time to dig deep
into the comic pages and explore the
untold truths of Legion ask the team
superhero teams are filled with weirdos
with superpowers looking for redemption
and they don't get weirder Marvel's
various axe teams one lurking you'll see
that they are stocked with animal-themed
berserkers with metal bones a guy named
Cyclops you have two eyes and an
occasional creep with way way too much
skin whose superhero name is also skin
which is somehow a useful power Legion
has occasionally hung around with the
x-men and was almost a regular member of
x-factor as well but that plan fizzled
out when writer Peter David put his foot
down even in a world where readers are
meant to accept super-powered characters
running around and skin fights outfits
David felt nobody would be able to
accept that a character too unstable to
leave a mutant sanctuary island could
serve as a superhero
of course mental stability isn't exactly
a trademark of most superheroes but
Legion was just too much to handle in
the early 90s of course unstable
superheroes would become a trademark of
later Marvel Comics but with every known
and unknown superhero power lurking in
his brain
why would Legion need a team anyhow
that's like saying Justin Timberlake
really needed NSYNC it's madness magneto
stole his inheritance ask any mad
supervillain and they'll tell you the
asteroid bases don't come cheap if you
want to go big you have to threaten
world governments robbed a whole lots of
banks or just steal a pile of gold from
a traumatized Holocaust survivor like in
uncanny x-men number 161
the reason that arch frenemies Professor
X and Magneto met in the first place is
a lady named Gabrielle Haller who shows
up when magneto was volunteering at an
Israeli hospital because the woman is
abnormally traumatized they call in
noted miracle worker Charles Xavier
to help her out Xavier discovers her
terrible path of the hands of Nazis who
only kept her alive because she knew the
load
of a major stash of gold never once
emits an opportunity Baron Strucker and
Hydra attack intent on finding the gold
and Xavier and Magneto have their first
real team-up or trying to rescue
Gabrielle like anyone on a long road
trip magneto and the professor realized
that their beliefs don't really mesh so
magneto ends up liberating all this
stash of gold
Xavier meanwhile ends up getting the
girl which ultimately leads to legions
birth destroy all humans the Marvel
Universe is full of people who can read
your thoughts to control your thoughts
and just generally mess up your thoughts
on a hundred levels the x-men alone both
Professor X and the frost Jean Grey and
sly Locke this metric ton of mind
powered mutants came into play when the
villain Shadow King took control of
Legion and revealed that he was a threat
for the entire world among his other
weird abilities the Shadow King is able
to feed off of negative energy so in
uncanny x-men number two seven eight he
sets plans in motion to hijack
Allegiance body and along with the
captured mutant Polaris who also happens
to be Magneto's daughter manages to
increase fear and hatred across the
entire globe shadow Kings manipulations
reveal some particularly troubling stuff
above legions power basically he's
always just a single thought away from
ending life as we know it and he's
possibly the most powerful omega-level
mutant somewhere in the range of mr.
fantastics nerdy kid Franklin and Billy
Corgan the Age of Apocalypse you know
that whole thing about stepping on a
butterfly in the past and changing the
future and terrible and unexpected ways
oh I wish I wish I hadn't killed that me
apparently
Allegiant doesn't during one of his most
lucid periods Legion realized that he
was suffering from some pretty heavy
abandonment issues rather than join a
support group for people who have been
abandoned by the psychic jobs Legion
decided that his magneto hadn't always
been fighting his pop and he would have
made more time for Legion his solution
was simple
kill magneto in the pages of x-men
number forty-one Legion hops into the
past and tried to kill Magneto
but Xavier ended up sacrificing himself
to save Magneto instead without the
powerful Professor X creating the x-men
that constantly brought the evil mutant
apocalypse there was no one to stop the
villain
taking over America and ushering in the
creatively named Age of Apocalypse as
the Legion he became a living version of
the grandfather paradox as he can no
longer be born because of his
time-traveling shenanigans or until
another writer wanted to use them again
god-killer so Legion can drive every
human on earth insane and time-travel to
usher in the literal apocalypse but
topping the list of dangerous things
that Legion can do with his powers is
probably his ability to kill God in New
Mutants number 21 the mystical mutant
magic needs to defeat the Elder Gods who
tormented her while she was stuck in
limbo who have just come through a
portal and are threatening to destroy
Earth apparently magic learned a lot
about Devil's bargains while she was
trapped with demons so she summons
Legion specifically so he can destroy
gods which he does with a single thought
in her words part of Legion is the god
mutants which is a pretty intense thing
that was on a business card while it's
frightening to think of Legion as the
face of any kind of divinity his power
to destroy both gods and men is
unquestionable
he's been erased it's an open secret
that death has lost any real meaning in
comic books and it's always just a
matter of time and action figures sales
until writers and editors find some way
to bring dead heroes back to life like
most super people Legion has died before
multiple times in fact but what makes
him different from other characters is
that he's actually been erased from
existence the first time happened during
the Age of Apocalypse storyline which
we've already discussed the next time
Legion peace south it was by choice in
x-men legacy number 24 he looks at the
damage he's caused and worrying that
he'd still do a lot more in the future
decides to erase all traces of himself
despite his ultimate power remnants of
Legion remained behind for whatever
writer wants to tangle with them next
he's biblical one of the more
provocative aspects of Legion as a
character is that his name is
intentionally derived from the Bible
specifically a passage about the month
obsessed by demons who runs into Jesus
to ask the possessed man his name his
response was quoted appropriately enough
by a demon dude named black heart in
Marvel's first Ghost Rider movie
I named the bible's Legion is chock-full
of demons too strong to be held by
chains and kept in isolation so Marvel's
version isn't too far off the biblical
Legion has a happy ending when Jesus was
able to exorcise the demons out of his
body and into a herd of 2,000 pigs who
quickly drowned themselves which Pizza
would probably have some huge problem
with conversely it seems like a comic
book version of Legion can never be
fully cleansed of his personalities and
must suffer with his demons every day
it's possible that his biblical name
points to an eventual Redemption but
until then the character will remain
trapped in its fascinating personal
health bad for Legion great for fans of
surreal comic books television thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]